finding love can be tough in any city or
town but where you live might actually
play a bigger role than you think
there's a new study from wallet Hub on
the best cities and worst cities in
America to be single the study ranked
more than 180 cities on factors like the
percentage of the population that is
single the average price for a
two-person meal and the number of
attractions at the bottom of the list
are Fort Smith Arkansas Hialeah Florida
Brownsville Texas and Glendale
California and the worst city to be
single Warwick Rhode Island
the study found that the top five best
cities were dating are Portland Oregon
San Francisco Denver Madison Wisconsin
and the number one is Seattle now if
you're wondering about New York City it
was ranked number 151 out of 182.
and I just heard that Las Vegas ranks
number 11 for the best so that's pretty
good for us I can't imagine why I was
given the section of the show though but
speaking of being single and
relationships as we head into the new
year it's time to assess how yours are
right especially the romantic ones so we
have author Jesse Farrell here with some
expert by some relationship expert
advice and you wrote a book so you would
know what you're talking about yeah we
know a few things actually yeah Lisa
Farrell my business partner and wife and
colleague and she's my everything she
also we co-wrote this together I love
that I love that now what would you say
we would find in this book in general
you can't break it all down you know but
in general fair enough in general what
you're going to find is how to build and
maintain the best most powerful longest
lasting relationships and the question
is how do you do that number one number
one that's a good question I'm listening
learn to communicate oh that is number
one it's the number one breakdown in
relationship can I say amen amen number
two number two would be be mindful of
who you're communicating with and seek
to communicate in their style and their
language not just your own okay okay now
why are many relationships you know they
find a Breaking Point after it gets
exciting
I think because what happens is they're
they're they're they're compelled to be
moved by that love that it's like you
say the excitement the attraction and
they're not thinking about what each
other with each with each of them in the
relationship truly want they never even
talk about what they want they don't
they don't tell each other and
oftentimes they forget to tell
themselves right so at some point they
stop connecting because they're not
getting what they want interesting or
need out of the relationship so you need
to know your partner but you really need
to know yourself start with self first
so self-love everybody okay now let's
talk about um relationship Comfort this
is a concept you created just explain
what that means in in simple
relationship Comfort it's this is what
happens whenever you're making a
connection with the typically uh someone
that's really close to you okay a loved
one it's it happens with wives husbands
children's best friends boyfriends
girlfriends the closer and more intimate
the relationship is typically the more
relationship Comfort happens now you
want to be comfortable in your
relationship yeah that's important not
so comfortable that you forget
think of this you do things to that
person that you wouldn't do to anybody
else you don't do things for that other
person that you do for many other people
why because you're comfortable that
they're always going to be there oh that
part it's called that part yes that
would be the that would be the downside
of relationship Comfort it's sinking
into that and not ever realizing you
don't even know what you don't know
absolutely absolutely now any advice
really quick for singles out there you
know headed into the new year the first
thing I would say for singles is you
want to you want to reach out and
pre-order this book that's the first
place first things first that's the
first thing you want to pre-order that
you can do that at justtalk.com
j-e-s-s-t-a-l-k.com get on the list for
this okay secondly when you get this
book read the book
don't just order the book yes don't make
it look good on the table right right
read the book and if you have a comment
or a question and you need help reach
out to us because we're available okay
even without for pay right now
we can slide in the DM yes
see you and your lovely wife here so
thank you for sharing your wisdom with
us I'm going to go ahead and take this
copy right here
thank you Jesse
now the lunar year
fast approaching and the Grand Canal
shops have a thrill